[Musique]
on va poursuivre tout de suite avec
charme milliards qui pdg de la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec mon sort monsieur milliards en ce
moment c'est tendu donc de l'aide
prolonger mais restreinte pour les
entreprises là en fonction de leur
situation qu'est ce que vous pensez de
la formule adoptée par ottawa je pense
que votre collègue l'a très bien
expliqué c d excellentes nouvelles qui
nous viennent de tahoua aujourd'hui on
de la communauté d'affaires a
l'impression d'avoir été entendus ça
fait des huées semaines et même des mois
qu'on demande la fin de la pcr et une
reconversion vers d'autres sites d'agc
pour les travailleurs qui sont encore
dans le besoin alors on est très
satisfaits puis aussi la prolongation
des mesures dont entre autres programmes
d'embauché pour la relance économique et
un certain volume de subventions
salariales parce que même si on n'y
comprend le corps est dans une certaine
embellie certaines d'éclaircies dans
plusieurs secteurs d'activité mais
encore des secteurs où c'est difficile
et 26 riz de papier cette semaine entre
autres sur le secteur culturel ou bien
que les salles plus elles peuvent être
occupés maintenant à 100% les gens ne
sont pas nécessairement présent alors
c'est la même chose dans ce secteur
touristique on n'a pas eu le cycle d'une
année pour se reprendre alors c'est
normal qu'ils aient acquis cet effet
entonnoir mais le fait que ce soit la
fin du mur à mur c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour justement programme
spécifique pour l'industrie du tourisme
et de l'accueil annoncé aujourd'hui mais
seulement pour celui là est ce que c'est
suffisant à votre avis
mais écoutez moi je suis je suis
d'accord que le premier ministre hugo
qui dit que c'est logique d'arrêter
d'avoir des solutions qui sont eux qui
sont trop larges alors dans une
perspective de finances publiques il
avait mentionné ça coûte et 289
milliards alors c'est un joug de 2,7
milliards c'est normal que ce soit un
peu plus restrictif maintenant si c'est
trop restrictif et qu'on pense à côté de
l'objectif parce que les gens ne sont
pas capables d'avoir accès à l'argent on
pourra en reparler et pour le moment
c'est certain que les secteurs les plus
touchés c'est ce qui aurait été
identifié par par le gouvernement alors
nous on est satisfait de ce côté là mais
ce que vous croyez justement qui en a
des entreprises qui font pas partir du
secteur touristique n'est qu' qui vivent
des difficultés en raison de la pandémie
et killer en raison des critères qui ont
été énoncées aujourd'hui ça va être
difficile pour eux ça va être un fardeau
administratif de démontrer qu'ils
subissent toujours les conséquences de
tout ça pour avoir de la haine
écoutez je pense je pense à des membres
chez nous très précisément qui vont
devoir faire cette démonstration l'homme
encore une fois dans une perspective de
finances publiques avoir un comportement
citoyen je pense qu'après près 300
milliards de dépenses est normal de
devoir faire une justification il faut
simplement s'assurer que les gens aient
accès à l'argent quand on a fait le
début de la subvention salariale il ya
des pans entiers de l'économie qui
avaient pas accès parce que les règles
étaient pas suffisamment clair alors
donnons la chance au coureur mais c'est
évident que yoyo
il ya des gens à l'extérieur du dossier
du secteur touristique qui vont avoir
besoin d'accords ouest l'a dit monsieur
milliards comme vous le savez ces
programmes-là devait prendre fin le 23
octobre c'est samedi et là on l annonce
trois jours avant l'entrée en vigueur
d'un nouveau programme de la fin de
certains programmes ça ça laisse pas
beaucoup de temps là vos membres
retourné là si vous voulez c'est plutôt
rapide mais écoutez si on parle de
prolonger une aide on va pas on va pas
de chimie non plus là dessus pour ce
qu'il a fait hier je conviens que c'est
assez rapide mais en même temps je pense
que les gens devraient s'y attendre
parce que ça fait longtemps que
plusieurs acteurs qui mentionne qu'on
devrait faire diriger les gens qui ont
encore besoin vers d'autres programmes
comme l'assurance emploi qui va
d'ailleurs subir aussi une réforme dans
le prochain gouvernement doit s'arrêter
sur
mesure les programmes là qui sont
prolongées on parle d'une prolongation
de six mois jusqu'au 7 mai 2000 22 ans
christophe et lydie l'économie presque
remise à 100% de cette crise est que
c'est justifié ces six mois de plus pour
les prestations que c'est une excellente
nouvelle que ce qu'on ait enfin un peu
de prévisibilité parce qu'on était
souvent pratiquement au mois ou deux
mois avant d'avoir six mois je pense que
madame filets n'ont probablement pas au
secteur touristique à l'hôtellerie pour
qu'ils puissent avoir un site complet de
reprise économique avant de pouvoir
c'est alors dans la mesure où les
critères sont suffisamment claires et
restrictif offert une bonne gestion des
finances publiques moi je pense une
excellente nouvelle
qu'on donne le plus de prévisibilité
possible aux entreprises concernées je
vous entends monsieur millan vous
semblez heureux d'à peu près tout ce qui
a été annoncé aujourd'hui et je présume
y compris de la fin de la pcr eux c'est
ça doit être frais de moins pour l'
embauche pour les entreprises alors
jésus et critique quand paul lay mais là
je vous avoue qu'aujourd'hui surface a
été entendu ce sont des bonnes nouvelles
et je rappelle aux gens qui touchent la
paix seraient en ce moment qu'ils
m'écoutent on ne dit pas que vous ne
devez pas recevoir d'être ainsi que
d'autres programmes et que la paix c'est
en ce moment qu'il ancien pc d'ailleurs
les gens l'appellent encore le paie
souvent envoyé un mauvais signal quand
on pense qu'en 995 mais le poste vacant
encore au québec alors mettez vous dans
la peau des entrepreneurs quand il voit
une mesure comme super dur pour ce une
bonne nouvelle est ce que vous pensez
même qu'avec la fin de la pcr eux dès le
mois d'octobre dès le mois de novembre
on pourrait avoir un impact dans
l'embauché dans l'auto postes vacants
ben c'est à souhaiter je pense que
chaque chaque millier d'emplois comble
on va l'accueillir évidemment ce n'est
pas la solution à combler l'ensemble les
pénuries de main d'oeuvre j'en suis très
conscient par contre des gens exemple
sont travers autonome qui pourrait être
tenté de se diriger vers un emploi
salarié pour la prochaine année où les
prochaines années alors honnêtement pour
les entrepreneurs on reprend tout ce
qu'ils pensent pour régler ce problème
nous entendons merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là monsieur milliards merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit